-Performing the title track
to her album, "In Real Life,"
once again, Mandy Moore!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-♪ I just got a front-row seat
to real life ♪
♪ And now I gotta open up
my eyes ♪
♪ It's too late to wait
until it feels right ♪
♪ Now I gotta start
the long goodbye ♪
♪ I spent every day,
filling every page ♪
♪ How the world revolved
around me ♪
♪ When I saw your face ♪
♪ I knew right away ♪
♪ We'd be whoever
we wanted to be ♪
♪ In real life ♪
♪♪
♪ Somebody loves me ♪
♪ In real life ♪
♪♪
♪ Somebody needs me ♪
♪ I've been seeing friends of
mine in real life ♪
♪ Going through the motions ♪
♪ Spinning wheels,
spinning their wheels ♪
♪ Everything is happening
in real time ♪
♪ Rising tide is nipping at
my heels ♪
♪ But I'm different now,
I'm not sure how ♪
♪ The world don't revolve
around me ♪
♪ Coming out of the dark ♪
♪ With you in my arms ♪
♪ We see whatever we needed
to see ♪
♪ In real life ♪
♪♪
♪ Somebody loves me ♪
♪ In real life ♪
♪♪
♪ Somebody needs me ♪
♪ In real life ♪
♪♪
♪ The curtains were drawn ♪
♪ The circus moved on ♪
♪ Once I saw who I was
in your eyes ♪
♪ Now each minor key
sounds major to me ♪
♪ And everything feels
harmonized ♪
♪♪
♪ Somebody loves me ♪
♪ Somebody needs me ♪
♪ In real life ♪
♪♪
♪ Somebody wants me ♪
♪ In real life ♪
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]